[MUSIC PLAYING]
Stanford lies at the
heart of Silicon Valley.
And when you think
of Silicon Valley
and by implication
Stanford, you think
of the people who take
risks, break boundaries.
That's the reason why I
think Stanford, indeed,
is a unique place to
understand innovation
and entrepreneurship.
We have cherry
picked, to be honest,
the best Stanford
faculty we can find
in entrepreneurship
and innovation.
On one hand you'll
have people who
will do a more
rigorous research,
like my colleague,
Hayagreeva Rao.
On the other hand, you'll have
folks like Perry Klebahn, who
actually invented
the modern snowshoe.
So we have that sort of range
of folks, to bring together,
if you will, the rigorous
and the relevant.
What the certificate program and
the courses in the certificate
program do is they inform people
about cutting edge practices.
They illuminate
principles underlying
innovation and entrepreneurship.
But most of all,
they inspire people.
So that you can go
out and innovate
and be an entrepreneur
in your own company
or in your own
corner of the world.
Taught by world renowned
faculty from the Graduate
School of Business and
the School of Engineering,
the Stanford Innovation and
Entrepreneurship certificate
is a self-paced
interactive online program,
where you will gain essential
skills and effective strategies
to generate and
implement new ideas.
There are many
features that Stanford
can offer to make the
Innovation and Entrepreneurship
certificate suit the needs
of your organization.
Your company's private
branded landing page
is the hub of your program.
From the landing
page, participants
can enter the discussion forum,
preview upcoming webinars,
join the virtual
study hall, connect
with other participants,
read about the faculty,
and access their courses.
Each course is
divided into modules
and contains lectures,
interactive assignments,
and readings.
Throughout the course,
the Stanford teaching team
will provide participants with
feedback on select assignments,
challenging them to
apply their knowledge
and hone their
innovation skills.
There are a number of
courses to choose from,
so you can customize
the program to fit
the needs of your organization.
So one of our design
principles in the classes
is anywhere you have
good internet access,
you can take a class.
So your employees
throughout your company
get to be exposed to
them in a way where
they have control over
their time and can pace it.
What companies can do is
signal to their high potential
individuals, hey,
you're valuable.
We need you, we want you.
One of the things
about innovation
is if you want to do
better, you better
spread it throughout
the organization.
If you're working even
in a large company,
and you want to make sure
that your large company has
the soul of a startup,
this program's
a great place to begin with.